foreign
hi
welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
energy is the most valuable resource in
our modern world without it nothing
moves nothing is produced and nothing
gets done and it's not because we all
suddenly become lazy slobs but rather
the modern world becomes impossible so
what if we had a form of energy
production that produces no waste no
carbon dioxide no methane no dangerous
radioactive material and no form of rare
fuel required this is the promise of
Fusion Energy it sounds like a pipe
dream and has been for the past 80 years
but fairly recently something has
changed
on December 5th 2022 the Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratory in
California did the impossible for the
first time in human history using Fusion
Energy they produced more energy than
they put in
a lot of experts thought that this would
be impossible for the foreseeable future
but while this achievement is ample
cause for celebration all is not as it
seems in this episode we'll take a look
Fusion TV
since its devastating use in the atomic
bomb in the 1940s it didn't take long
for scientists to figure out something
very clever instead of splitting atoms
apart to create energy called efficient
reaction in theory it would be possible
to fuse the atoms together to create
energy this is called a fusion reaction
if done correctly it could be a very
useful source of generating clean power
youthful is actually an understatement
in fact unlike traditional nuclear bombs
hydrogen or other wires that contain at
least some part fission reactions or
nuclear power stations that also split
atoms apart a fusion reactor would
produce no long-term radiation or
radioactive waste in fact the main
byproduct is helium and some neutrons
further to this there's very little
environmental impact and the fuel is
abundant in essence wherever there's
water there's fuel for a fusion reactor
while this isn't entirely true and it
could actually be a big problem but
we'll get to that later on in the video
when we talk about the issues with
fusion power
but another positive is that meltdowns
are impossible this is because it
actually requires energy to keep a
fusion reaction going if there's any
kind of problem the reaction stops in a
matter of seconds because there's no
energy to keep the reaction going
and lastly and best of all if you're
using atoms together creates four
million times more unit energy than
burning coal or gas and four times as
much energy as the more dangerous
nuclear fission used in traditional
power stations that is splitting atoms
apart
so you might be wondering doesn't
nuclear energy lead to Radioactive
disasters don't atomic bombs use nuclear
energy
well it turns out atoms like to stay
together and they don't like to be
broken apart so when you do this there's
a great deal of harmful radiation but
when you fuse atoms together it's not so
much the case
and for those who know a bit more about
Atomic Tech you'd be thinking about
hydrogen bombs well yes Fusion is a part
of it but the fusion part is only there
to Aid the fission part
the fusion part involves uranium which
is still a very dangerous material
funnily enough Fusion is completely
natural
a proof of it just look up at the sky
during the daytime
it's called The Sun It's a giant Fusion
reactor in the sky if we could do this
on Earth and control the energy released
it would be the biggest change to the
course of human history the feet is
almost impossible but the benefit is so
great that it's worth a shot
a lot of scientists thought so too
so scientists around the world have been
getting to work to make it happen
[Music]
so how does Fusion work exactly well
bear with me on this next part because
the understanding of this is crucial to
the understanding of the rest of the
episode
under ordinary circumstances Atomic
nuclei carry a positive electrical
charge
this positive charge repels the nuclei
so they don't get too close to each
other
frankly they hate being next to each
other like two friends who have fallen
out but when heated to temperatures of
millions of degrees the electrons say
sayonara and leave the nuclei are now
vibrating around like crazy in a
superheated soup called plasma
in this plasma State the positively
charged nuclei can get enough speed and
energy to overcome their Mutual dislike
for each other and when they get close
enough a new short range Force takes
over called the strong nuclear force and
when this takes hold the nuclei combine
and fuse and when this Fusion happens
energy is released
and the cool thing is you don't need a
lot of matter to create a lot of energy
you probably all know E equals m c
squared it's a very powerful equation
just to give you an idea converting 700
milligrams of mass into pure energy is
equivalent to the energy of the bomb
dropped on Hiroshima
elements such as hydrogen and helium are
used because these atoms require less
energy to overcome their natural
repulsion to each other
and just as a side note the Sun and
other stars can overcome the repulsion
of atomic nuclei intrinsically due to
the immense gravity generated because of
their huge mass
essentially the gravity just squishes
the atoms together so Fusion can occur
so back here on Earth how exactly do you
beat nature and fuse these atoms
together
well in order to get atoms to overcome
their opposition to each other you have
to get them moving really really fast
and in a confined space
the goal is to create a high energy
state of matter
there are two main ways to do this but
the one we'll focus on for now is called
internal confinement Fusion or ICF this
is where a tiny capsule containing
hydrogen fuel is blasted with lasers for
less than a billionth of a second
but why for such a short period Well if
these lasers were fired for any longer
period of time the energy from the
lasers would spread out over a larger
area and the pressure and temperature
inside the fuel Target wouldn't be high
enough to cause the atoms to fuse
after blipping the lasers the hydrogen
fuel heats up and expands resulting in a
reflective shock wave that compresses it
the density becomes so high and the
nuclei are so close to each other that
the probability of collision is high
under these conditions some of the
nuclei fuse and some of their mass is
directly converted into energy in
accordance to E equals m c squared as
discussed earlier
okay so that's all well and good but how
come this is taking so long
over the course of decades it has been
very slow going for Atomic Fusion Energy
as the publication Fox so eloquently put
it Fusion reactors so far are like using
a blow torch to light a match sure it
works but the energy that you've put
into light that match was excessive for
the small flame of energy that you get
out
[Music]
As Time wore on there was little to show
for Fusion and the investment into
Fusion Energy never grew and progress
started to slow
in 1997 the United States Department of
energy decided to throw their weight
fully behind Fusion Energy
you see the National Academy of Sciences
a private organization but official
advisor to the US government stated that
one of America's goals should be viable
Fusion Energy
to be viable ignition needs to be
achieved this simply means more energy
out of the fuel Target than the amount
of energy hitting the fuel Target
to achieve this goal the national
ignition facility was built
construction started in 1997 and
concluded in 2009
when experiments started things didn't
go so well
by 2012 they had only achieved 10
percent of the conditions needed for
ignition
after this the facility was then
converted and partially used for you
guessed it weapons research
you see this was very disappointing for
the Americans because even as far back
as 1997 the Europeans had already
achieved 67 of ignition conditions they
were using a more widely accepted and
thought to be more feasible method and
we'll get to this later in the episode
but the Americans persisted and they
started to get closer and closer and
closer
in 2021 they ended up getting 70 of the
way there but in late 2022 they made
some improvements to the fuel Target
design and in one Fell Swoop achieving
154 of ignition conditions they got more
energy out of the reaction than they put
in
on December 5th 2022 the American team
turned on one of the most powerful
lasers in the world they stood by as 192
laser beams smashed into a tiny fuel
pallet two megajoules of energy went
into the laser beams and three
megajoules came out
America had beaten the Europeans to this
moment an energy secretary Jennifer
granholm could Relish in this fact quote
this is what it looks like for America
to take the lead and we're just getting
started
in the scientific Community the reaction
around the world was ecstatic Carolyn
currents a plasma physicist at the
University of Michigan States
quote the result clearly surpasses that
Mark leaving no question that they have
achieved Fusion ignition in the
laboratory
Tammy ma who leads the lab's laser
Fusion research initiatives got the call
while waiting for a plane and I burst
into tears it was just tears of joy and
I actually physically started shaking
and jumping up and down
in in you know at the gate before
everybody boards so everybody was like
what is that crazy woman doing in the
tubes the laser beams Amplified by
racing back and forth and the Flash is a
fraction of a second we have to get to
these incredible conditions hotter
denser than the center of the Sun and so
we need all of that laser energy to get
to these very high energy densities all
that Wallop vaporizes a Target nearly
too small to see can I hold this thing
absolutely
get on there you know
unbelievable the Precision that we need
for making these shells is Extreme the
shells are almost perfectly round they
have a roughness that is 100 times
better than a mirror you think about
that if it wasn't smoother than a mirror
imperfections would make the implosion
of atoms uneven causing a fusion fizzle
so these need to be as close to perfect
as humanly possible that's right
this way and we do think there are among
the most perfect items that we have on
Earth
they build 1500 a year to make 150
nearly perfect
why does it have to be so small
the laser gives us only a finite amount
of energy the target could be larger but
then the laser would have to be larger
on December 5th they used a thicker
Target so it would hold its shape longer
and they figured out how to boost the
power of the laser shot without damaging
the lasers
this is the first look at what's left of
the target assembly That Changed History
an artifact like Belle's first phone or
Edison's light bulb this thing is going
to end up in the Smithsonian
but before everyone celebrates there's
still a lot of work to be done to make
fusion a viable source of abundant clean
energy
there's a vast amount of engineering
optimization needed here let's see what
that is exactly
amazing as it is so far the Breakthrough
just isn't practical the national
ignition facility itself is just a
research laboratory first and foremost
they're essentially testing the
feasibility of the theory the technology
is not intended to produce power so
designing an actual whole Fusion reactor
to harness this new approach will be in
its own right a massive engineering
challenge
in news Publications it's widely stated
that the lab produced 1.5 times as much
energy than was used to cause the
reaction by the lasers but there's a
massive catch this measurement only
accounts for the energy in a very narrow
way it only considers the actual laser
energy hitting the fuel Target if this
method is to be feasible for the energy
grid you have to account for the energy
needed to power the lasers themselves
taking that into account the total
amount of energy output would need to be
roughly 66 times more than was produced
another limitation is that the facility
can only fire a few laser shots per day
and the amount of electricity needed can
sometimes cause blackouts in the lab to
run an actual Fusion reactor you'd need
about 10 shots per second
another massive issue is what I touched
on earlier about the fuel source
the fuel source for Fusion reactors are
two isotopes of hydrogen deuterium and
tritium now deuterium is plentiful about
one in every 5000 hydrogen atoms in the
ocean are deuterium and it sells for
about 13 dollars per gram but tritium on
the other hand is extremely rare to
produce the material costs about thirty
thousand dollars per gram so this is a
major issue
but on the bright side Fusion reactors
themselves do produce tritium as a
byproduct so ultimately it would have to
be a matter of capturing it effectively
right now in the world there's only a
few kilograms of commercially available
tritium
but the hope is in the far future as
Fusion reactors come online we'll be
able to obtain more of that material
though getting adequate fuel is going to
be a really hard problem to solve but
there are some much easier problems to
look at first namely the combustion of
the hydrogen fuel itself it's not
burning that effectively
Troy Carter a plasma physicist at the
University of California explained quote
the national ignition facility shot only
burned a small fraction of the fuel in
the capsule if you can find a way to
burn up more fuel the gain goes up
substantially
this will of course involve more
tweaking to get all that laser energy
directed towards compressing those
hydrogen atoms
interestingly the biggest gains could be
made from the lasers themselves the
national ignition facility is using
outdated technology
the lasers are only one percent
efficient in terms of turning
electricity into laser light while
modern designs can be 20 efficient
Kim boodle director of The Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratory said this
quote the national ignition facility is
built on 1980s Laser Technology
so even with the same setup just by
using better lasers and targeting the
fuel more efficiently there could be
plenty more energy output to gain
I kind of see this whole situation as
equivalent to the first transistor
versus a fully working silicon chip of
the early 1980s we have the concept but
in order to make it practical there
still has to be orders of magnitude of
engineering breakthrough is needed
so the national ignition facility may
have proven that their method is viable
but is it the best way forward or a dead
end well it's hard to say but this is
where the other approaches of nuclear
fusion come into play
in the race for Fusion Energy there are
two main methods the internal
confinement method using lasers which is
what I've talked about so far but
there's another version that uses
magnets it's called magnetic confinement
Fusion the most common way to achieve
this is by using electromagnets
microwaves and particle beams to heat
hydrogen gas and turn it into plasma
this plasma gets squeezed by
superconducting magnets in a
donut-shaped ring when the plasma is hot
enough and the atoms are close enough
together Fusion can occur and a large
amount of energy is released
and this method is the widely accepted
method and until December of 2022 it was
the method that was generally thought to
lead to ignition
this magnetic form of fusion is how the
iter the world's largest Fusion project
currently under construction in the
southern France will generate the
reaction after fusion occurs heat from
the reaction can be used to warm water
heat it up to become Steam and this
steam can drive a turbine to produce
energy this last part is basically how
every form of major grid energy is
produced from coal to nuclear the energy
is simply used to heat up steam to drive
turbines thinking about it it sounds a
little inefficient but there may be a
better way
more recently there's been a third
method a nuclear fusion generator called
post compression this method doesn't
heat up steam but can provide electrical
energy directly there's an amazing video
by real engineering which I recommend
watching for further information
what I am sharing right now is going to
be studied by nuclear physicists around
the world trying to reverse engineer the
world changing machine this is Trenta
helion's sixth generation nuclear fusion
generator this fusion generator is
unlike any other using a completely
novel approach to achieve nuclear fusion
adapting knowledge developed for ION
propulsion in Space the generator forms
two mirrored rings of Plasma on either
end of a reactor and in a tenth of a
thousandth of a second they fire them at
each other sequentially activating
powerful magnets to squeeze and compress
the Rings towards the center where they
Collide converting the astonishing
kinetic energy of the ions traveling at
300 kilometers per second into thermal
energy raising the plasma temperature to
tens of millions of degrees hot enough
to overcome the electromagnetic
repulsion keeping the ions apart and
allowing them to fuse forming new atoms
and releasing a tremendous amount of
energy in the process
this isn't the world of fairy tale this
is already happening I watched the
bright pink flash of fusion multiple
times inside the control room of Trenta
what helion is doing right now is
astounding the sequence of events to
cause Fusion in this machine is a
delicate Symphony of electronics pushing
two plasma Rings into a violent
collision and catching that Collision in
a magnetic trap in the center which
proceeds to shrink until the ions
trapped within it have nowhere else to
go but to fuse overcoming one of the
universe's strongest forces to create
new elements in the belly of a man-made
machine but helion isn't done they are
already building the next step in their
quest for Clean safe energy for
humankind Polaris will also be the first
generation to begin capturing
electricity but that's a lot easier said
than done and will need the very latest
Electronics to work quickly enough
so in conclusion while Fusion Energy is
largely still a dream it's come one
large step closer to reality thanks to
the National ignition facility but
there's still likely Decades of work
ahead of us but who knows there could be
a technological breakthrough in Material
Science new methods or other facets of
technology and we could see a
breakthrough sooner than we think
I'm personally interested to see what
independent groups come up with those
like helion using their pulsed
compression technique if scientists are
willing to share their knowledge and
collaborate and maybe even future AI
systems could help with this Fusion
Energy may no longer be a pipe dream
so thanks for watching hope you enjoyed
that if you did feel free to take a look
around the channel there's plenty of
interesting stuff around here and yes
I've finally done a video on Fusion on
the channel cold fusion alright so I'll
see you again soon for the next episode
my name is and you've been watching
cold fusion cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking